Oh
the Second World War goes beyond all
boundaries in every category we see more
nations involved in a single conflict we
see casualties higher than ever before
just a generation before at the end of
the First World War the Great War they
didn't call it World War one because
they expected that nothing like this
would ever happen again and a generation
later something happens that's even
bigger and even worse in so many ways
we have the honor of making this year's
Call of Duty called World War 2 our
chance to tell the epic gritty visceral
story of the world's greatest conflict
there is a genuine interest in producing
a product that is historically authentic
every part of this this game has been
researched and nuanced and studied and
scanned and photographed we really
really try to get the respect in the
details riders this is about ordinary
people doing extraordinary things
Brotherhood - camaraderie
the guy next to me that became the team
for our kid on a personal level
honoring the story was crucial for us
and was something we really committed to
for a story weaves in and out of real
historical events we've gone to great
pains to create those authentic battles
one of the biggest things we wanted to
get across was a sense of camaraderie
the people you serve side by side with
you develop bonds with those people
hopefully players will walk away from
this story feeling like they really know
these guys welcome to the bloody first
and they care about that
art influences a game in a huge way the
lighting and the tonality and the colors
we want to be able to have the player
feel something by creating a very
believable environment it allows the
player to slip into this world the
vision for the art direction we call
dark and beautiful it was emotionally
dark visually beautiful more than just
being cool and pretty it's about trying
to get people to have a deeper emotional
reaction to the game our modeling
department is amazing
the weapons vehicles the tanks even the
cars you might see on the city street
the level detail is just phenomenal it's
a huge endeavor but we have to stay true
to the source material we have to
research and watch a lot of film a lot
of archive footage to see how Tibetans
in World War two would behave sometimes
the hardest things are the biggest
payoff the combination of the model the
animation and audio greats that
punchiness to the weapon we record
everything every location we recorded
for the game the ambience is the music
the dialogue everything has to be
created from scratch we had a real
opportunity here to do a level of
authenticity and reality true to the war
true to the soldiers who fought in that
war we had this great opportunity with
Marni Morgan our military advisor we
spent a lot of time on a gun range with
all of the authentic World War 2
weaponry it's critical to understand the
absolute violence of the Second World
War it's critical to understand how
weapons and firepower function this is a
story that's bigger than all of us this
is a whole new generation who might not
have a lot of experience with this time
period I think this is a great
opportunity to have them experience that
and feel that
we've made something pretty incredible
and I'm very proud of it it's perhaps
the greatest compliment I've been paid
in my career to work on this project
this is the most powerful game I've ever
worked on
it's very personal very humbling you
know I've been make engaged over 26
years and I'll tell you it's best get
labelmate
pre-order now and get access to the
private beta
you
you